i love your books i love the way you
write about history and uh you choose
your subjects very carefully
now uh lafayette uh this incredibly
important uh french character who
many people may not know much about but
somebody should write a book about it
someone should write a book about it is
my point and he plays a pivotal role in
the american revolution why don't you
tell people a little bit about lafayette
sure conan andy
here we go he was a frenchman he was a
teenager 19 years old he's an aristocrat
he's really he's an orphan he's the
richest orphan in france but he has
these ideals about the enlightenment and
also the british murdered his dad in a
previous war so he has a bone to pick
with them right so he comes over he
volunteers with george washington and
even though he's this kid and this
really fancy french kid he just like
rolls up his sleeves and like you know
gets in there and
he's wounded at the battle of brandywine
but like he's just raring to get back to
the front like he you know gets out of
his hospital bed and wraps his bum leg
in a blanket and rides back to the front
which is like the first and maybe the
last time in history a frenchman
like cut short his rest in recuperation
[Laughter]
so i'm just curious like all right so
you write about this what's interesting
about lafayette is
george washington's everybody's idol in
the revolution everybody idolized this
guy and george washington is not you
know but but he's hard to get to know
he's kind of aloof and he loves andy
kind of you know yeah exactly yeah
oh wait no not like andy at all this is
the wooden teeth yeah and he has wooden
teeth um
[Music]
but lafayette is this
teenage french rich kid who becomes
washington's like washington loves this
guy yeah well i mean for one thing
washington didn't have any kids and
lafayette was an orphan so they had kind
of you know
served that function i'm i don't i don't
know about psychology too much but there
was that bond but also like at the time
like washington there was this whole
conspiracy amongst the congress and some
other people in the army to fire george
washington you know and lafayette is
just on his side and just like backs him
up the whole way and um i think like
washington
appreciated his um
affection and his respect and you know
sure being like he had someone in his
corner like andy yeah
no it is andy george washington now or
lafayette i mean andy works in any
situation yeah okay right
i am the richest frenchman orphan today
yeah
uh you know what's uh do you think
there's a holiday message in your
lafayette book wouldn't that be nice if
there was a holiday message here because
the holidays coming up wouldn't that be
it was winter it was winter of 1777
right before christmas and the
continental army are going to their
winter quarters at valley forge they
don't have shoes there's snow on the
ground they have to march like 20 miles
in the snow um they're basically naked
you know these are like guys who are
trying to fight people called the red
coats and they don't even have shirts
you know and they get there there's no
food there's no water they have to build
their own huts and um like because they
don't have shoes they get frostbite some
of them have to have their like limbs
amputated
so like if your christmas maybe isn't
going well
like maybe the turkey is dry or you
didn't get the gift you wanted i think
you should look down and you like do you
have feet
all right do you have do you have shoes
well
at valley forge that's what we call a
merry christmas you know
i think that's a nice message
[Applause]